Traductor: María González Durán
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Seguro que muchos de vosotros
os habéis manchado los pies
de alquitrán alguna vez en la playa.
Yo sí. Muchas.
Sobre todo, de pequeño;
después de estar todo el día
en la orilla llegaba el momento de irse
a casa y había que sacudirse los pies
para subirse al coche.
Y nada. Ahí aparecía esa manchita negra
en la planta del pie.
La odiaba. Y no por la mancha en sí,
que me daba igual
sino por la fase posterior de limpieza
en la que mi madre con un algodoncito
manchado en aceite de oliva
se pasaba frotándome la planta del pie
toda la tarde del domingo.
Para mí en aquel momento, aquello formaba
parte de la playa, como el agua,
los peces... y como la arena.
Mucho tiempo después, en los días
posteriores al 13 de noviembre de 2002
se mostraban por televisión las terribles
consecuencias
del hundimiento del buque Prestige,
que se fue a pique a 250 km
de la costa gallega, tiñéndola de negro
con las 77 000 toneladas de fuel pesado
que llevaba en sus bodegas.
Esto es una muestra de la carga
que llevaba aquel barco en sus bodegas.
Fijaos.
Los que estáis arriba no lo oléis,
pero hacedme caso, huele fatal.
Fue observando esa marea humana de héroes
y heroínas que voluntariamente fueron
a recoger el chapapote
con sus manos a la playa
cuando me di cuenta de que aquello
que les manchaba sus trajes y manos
era exactamente igual que
lo que me manchaba a mí
la planta de los pies cuando era pequeño.
Y si no, se le parecía mucho.
Nunca he sabido de ningún accidente
enfrente de las costas de Málaga,
allí donde yo me bañaba de pequeño.
¿Sabéis lo que sí hubo
durante mucho tiempo?
Pues una plataforma de descarga
de productos petrolíferos.
Bueno, de las consecuencias de un vertido
en el mar hay amplia documentación.
Por resumir, malformaciones,
cambio de comportamiento,
muerte de peces y cetáceos, extinción
de especies vegetales y algas,
desaparición del plancton, que es
la base de la cadena alimenticia marina.
El petróleo, al degradarse en el mar,
desprende unas sustancias químicas
altamente cancerígenas. Pues eso sí
entra dentro de la cadena alimenticia.
Primero marina, y después humana.
Los peces al volar y ver las manchas
de petróleo en el mar
las confunden con islotes,
entonces se acercan
y quedan impregnadas
de la sustancia maldita.
Perdiendo muchas veces
su capacidad de vuelo
y otras lo que pierden es la
impermeabilización de sus plumas.
Condenadas igualmente a morir de frío.
La llegada de un vertido a costa, supone
unas consecuencias altamente dramáticas.
No hay manera humana de separar
el chapapote de la arena.
¿Y si el petróleo llega a las rocas?
A ver quién es el guapo que se va
con una Kärcher a darle con agua caliente
a presión a los espigones.
Y no lo digo en broma,
es que no hay otra manera.
Un vertido en costa es la desaparición
de playas, entornos naturales,
piscifactorías, caladeros de marisco.
En definitiva, consecuencias económicas
y medioambientales devastadoras.
Pero bueno, que yo no he venido a cortaros
el rollo con visiones catastróficas.
Yo os he venido a contar cómo
la tecnología nos va a ayudar a cuidar
de los océanos.
Tres mil millones de personas dependen
directamente de la biodiversidad marina.
Y nuestros océanos generan más oxígeno
que todos los bosques del planeta.
Bueno saltamos ahora seis años
y nos vamos a octubre de 2008.
En ese momento empiezo a trabajar en
un laboratorio de detección y análisis
de contaminación marina.
Y lo que más me gusta de mi trabajo
es que está a bordo de un avión.
Del avión de salvamento marítimo.
Sí, llevo diez años viendo manchas
de petróleo en el mar.
Y no solo a través de la ventana
sino gracias a un montón
de sensores de teledetección que
me permiten ver desde ahí arriba
todos los vertidos y podemos
detectarlos, medirlos y analizarlos.
Sin necesidad de tocar el agua.
En estos años he aprendido
un par de cosas muy interesantes.
La primera es que existen los aviones
en los que se puede estirar las piernas
cuando uno va sentado.
La segunda, que cada año terminan en el
mar desechos de productos petrolíferos
en una cantidad equivalente
a 20 veces la descarga del Prestige.
Y eso... ¿por qué no sale en los medios?
Porque solo la décima parte
es consecuencia de accidentes
como los del Prestige.
Según un estudio de la Academia
de Ciencias de Estados Unidos
realizado en 2003, hasta un 40 %
proviene de descargas operacionales
en la extracción y el transporte.
Dicho de otra manera, cada año se vierten
en el mar cientos de miles de toneladas
de desechos del petróleo
lanzados deliberadamente.
Con la única intención de ahorrarse
el dinero que cuesta reciclarlos.
Esto es básicamente lo mismo que si a mí
cuando me toca cambiar el aceite al coche
decido hacerlo en la playa para no pagar
la ecotasa que me cobra el taller.
Cientos de estas descargas operacionales,
un bonito eufemismo para no decir
crimen medioambiental, han sido vistas
desde nuestro avión todos estos años.
La mayoría de veces las detectamos
de forma aislada.
Pero algunas aparecen conectadas
a la estela en navegación de un buque.
En esos casos se inicia
un proceso sancionador
que suele acarrear fuertes multas.
Esto hará que la próxima vez
se lo piensen dos veces antes de hacerlo.
Este sistema de monitorización con aviones
y sobre todo de esas multas
han conseguido un efecto disuasorio que
nos ha permitido reducir sensiblemente
la contaminación en el mar.
Desgraciadamente, seguimos viendo
todavía muchas manchas.
¿Cuántas? Pues honestamente no tenemos
ni idea de la dimensión real del problema.
Y ya hemos visto que
el problema es muy serio.
No podemos cuidar lo que no conocemos.
Y no conocemos lo que no podemos ver.
Para eso, el mejor de los sensores
de nuestro avión puede ver 15 km
a cada lado del avión.
Aquí vemos una imagen de ese sensor
con una bonita estela contaminada.
En un vuelo de los nuestros somos capaces
de ver unos 30 000 km2 de contaminación.
No está nada mal,
es como cinco veces el área total
de la provincia de Granada.
Desgraciadamente, no podemos estar volando
todo el día y la mayoría de esos barcos
que deciden descargar ilícitamente sus
sentinas al mar lo hacen sin ser vistos.
La vista de pájaro está muy bien pero,
¿qué tal si subimos un poco más alto?
Por ejemplo, a 800 km,
a bordo de un satélite.
Esta es una imagen del satélite Envisat
tomada de la catástrofe del Prestige.
En una imagen tomada en unos pocos
segundos tenemos el conocimiento
de dónde está toda
la superficie contaminada.
Pudiendo actuar muy eficazmente
contra ese vertido.
Tardaríamos días en tener toda
esa información con nuestros aviones.
Os acordáis de que
la catástrofe del Prestige
su presencia en los medios de comunicación
era total.
No había telediario que no abriera sus
primeros minutos hablando del Prestige,
del hundimiento y
del chapapote en la playa.
Si algo bueno pudimos sacar de aquello
fue que se generó una conciencia ambiental
más o menos generalizada en todo el mundo.
¿No?
Bueno, a lo mejor no en todos. En unas
pocas millas al norte del Prestige...
...un par de barcos decidían descargar
sus sentinas también ilegalmente
aprovechando que el Pisuerga
pasa por Valladolid.
Durante todos estos años hemos tenido
unas ayudas muy interesantes.
La Unión Europea tiene establecido
un sistema de monitorización satelital
de la superficie marina; tiene ahora mismo
unos tres o cuatro satélites
de tecnología radar que nos dan
información de cada posición del mar
varias veces a la semana.
Esta es una imagen de uno de
esos satélites.
Tiene un ancho de barrido de 250 km.
Y también podemos ver
estelas contaminadas.
Toda esta información es enviada de forma
estrictamente confidencial a las agencias
de cada país encargadas de la lucha
contra la contaminación.
Ellos decidirán si actúan en consecuencia
en función de su normativa.
Saltamos ahora a un momento que
va a suponer un antes y un después
para todos los que nos dedicamos
a observar al planeta desde arriba.
En febrero de 2017, hace dos años,
las agencias espaciales norteamericanas
y europeas, la NASA y la ESA, deciden
liberar todas las imágenes
de todos sus satélites.
Solo es necesario hacerse una cuenta
en sus páginas webs y te puedes descargar
cualquier imagen de los mejores sensores
que existen en la actualidad.
Para facilitar ese análisis
se han abierto unos portales en Internet
con los que ver cualquier imagen de sus
sensores sin necesidad de descargarse.
Como el Google Maps pero del espacio.
Esto significa que cualquier persona
desde su casa con su ordenador personal
y una simple conexión a Internet puede
observar todo el planeta todos los días
con los mejores sensores del mundo.
No sé a vosotros, pero a mí
esto me vuela la cabeza.
Entonces, como la cabra tira al monte
me puse a investigar un poco
con los sensores de la Unión Europea.
Y sí, efectivamente, pude empezar a ver
las manchas que se hacían aquí en España.
Pero también las del resto
del Mediterráneo, el mar Rojo, y el Negro
y el Atlántico, y el Pacífico...
No os podríais creer la cantidad de
contaminación
que se puede observar
con un satélite de estos.
Es un problema global que
requiere soluciones globales.
Hasta ahora solo os he hablado
de tecnología radar, que es cojonuda
porque puede ver el planeta de día,
de noche, incluso a través de las nubes.
Es tan buena que toda la comunidad
científica siempre ha pensado, yo incluido
que es la única tecnología válida
para observar los vertidos en el mar.
Pero como resulta que entre todos estos
satélites gratuitos a nuestra disposición
gracias a la ESA y la NASA, hay un montón
de satélites que tienen otra tecnología.
Que es tecnología óptica. Básicamente como
si fueran cámaras de fotos con súper zoom
pero que además ven otros colores
que los humanos no vemos.
Sobre todo, en el espectro del infrarrojo.
Esos satélites están pensados sobre todo
para estudiar el clima y la vegetación
y sobre todo para ver paisajes
tan alucinantes como este.
Haciendo un paseo entre el desierto
de Gobi y el estrecho de Gibraltar,
por casualidad o por serendipia, me topé
con algo a lo que estoy acostumbrado a ver
desde la ventana de mi avión.
Eso es un barco descargando
todos sus desechos en el mar.
En el Mediterráneo, frente
a las costas de Argelia.
Estos sensores no están hechos
para ver el mar.
Menos mal, porque en pocas semanas en casa
tengo analizados y categorizados
más de 300 vertidos
solo en el Mediterráneo en 2018.
Y 30 buques in fraganti.
¿Y si además os digo que existen
11 satélites gratuitos libres...
...a todos vosotros con capacidad
de detectar un vertido?
Cualquiera de vosotros puede observar
cualquier tipo de crimen medioambiental
y ponerlo en conocimiento
de las agencias de todo el mundo
pero es que además existen
muchos satélites
de las propias agencias espaciales
de diferentes países
con capacidad para ver más vertidos.
Esos no están libres para todo el mundo
pero también pueden utilizarse.
Pero resulta que a día de hoy el espacio
se está democratizando.
La tecnología espacial ahora mismo
es exponencial y existen decenas
de constelaciones privadas que van a poner
en pocos años cientos de satélites
en órbita con capacidad
para ver un vertido.
De aquí a muy poco vamos a tener por fin
un conocimiento real y global
de la contaminación en el mar
y lo que es más importante,
podremos ver siempre quién la causa,
pudiendo actuar en consecuencia.
De aquí a poco, podremos acabar finalmente
con todos esos Prestige
que se hunden silenciosamente
enfrente de nuestras costas
pudiendo cuidar nuestra principal
fuente de alimento y oxígeno.
Y lo que es más importante:
que ningún niño vuelva a mancharse
los pies de alquitrán
en la playa fastidiando
sus tardes de verano.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)